Speaker 1: ed to when Trump was in
office? Well, I drive an electric car so
my gas hasn't changed, but I understand the
point. How about your grocery bill? Yes,
it's higher. But what does Joe Biden have to do
with that? How about everything you buy, bring
way up with the Democratic leadership? I don't
understand why you dummies can't look at numbers
instead of your personal political opinion. If
Biden and F.U. Well, that's exactly what I do,
regardless of my political opinion, which is
I prefer Biden to Trump. I have to look at the
numbers when it comes to gas prices, inflation,
et cetera. And when I look at the numbers,
I see that those things are up all over the
world and I see that those are not phenomena
that depend on the American president to any
significant degree. We I'm not going to do.
I respect you too much in the audience to do
my what can presidents do about gas prices ran
a second third, where it must be probably the
fifth time now. So I'm not going to do that.
But it is exactly because I do look at the facts
that I come to the conclusions I come to. And
Christopher or Keith, I don't know, is
welcome to call into my show any time.
And we can talk about it. Next, Gill wrote in
also about the Trump rally over the weekend
and said, You seem to laugh at Donald
Trump. I think you don't know very much. USA
is a corporation. USA Inc. Since yesterday,
USA become a republic like if! Was before.
And one more thing Donald know more than
you about political rules in Michigan. Well,
I couldn't possibly say it any better myself.
And this is just such a wholesale destruction
of my ideology and worldview that I won't even
try to respond to Gil because it's just too much.
I just it's just overwhelming. OK? Next e-mail
is from Darius. Darius says new subscriber here.
You killed air with Darlene. David, I stumbled on
your YouTube videos a couple of years ago and have
been evangelizing you to my friends and finally
decided it's time to pay for solid journalism. So
I am now a subscriber supporting the work you
do. I love it. Just remember I do commentary,
not journalism. Important distinction Darius
goes on to say, however, your interview with
Diana Swofford, it was Darlene so far. OK,
but it doesn't matter. I know who you mean.
Put you in the category of why doesn't this guy
have his own MSNBC or CNN? Show your interview?
Oh boy, was absolutely brilliant. You were
respectful, even complimentary. Your poker face
was amazing and critical to keep her from walking
off you past the oil issue. Brilliantly, dude, you
need an agent to up your game and get a broadcast
cable show. This country needs people like you.
Please try to do more interviews like these. Well,
I really appreciate that. I have an agent. We are
not trying to get me on MSNBC or CNN or Fox or
whatever. I'm very happy with what I'm doing.
I don't want to have 10 bosses at any of those
places. I don't think they want me there, either.
But I so appreciate the kind words from Darius
about this, and we are trying to get more of those
interviews lined up with 20 20 candidates on
the right and on the left. We're doing it all.
We're doing it all. Next, let's go to
an email from Theresa. Theresa said,
Is there a way I can gift more than one membership
at a time? David said on air that there were over
600 hoping to become members. I'd like to offer
several gifts anonymously. Thank you. Yeah. So
Theresa is asking a perfect question. One of
the biggest things people in the audience wanted
was they wanted to be able to gift memberships on
our website. They would write in. They would say,
Sir, I have a membership, but I want to
give some memberships away. Can I do that?
And up until two weeks ago, the answer was no. But
we listened we have a new plug in on our website.
Join Packman dot com, which when you go through
the checkout now there is a box and it says,
Is this a gift? And if you check the box,
your membership will be added to our queue,
which we can give away. We've given away about
100 membership so far thanks to gifts. But we do
have now it's not even six hundred, it's now
six hundred and seventy people waiting for a
membership. So we are going to try Theresa to
make this a possibility where you can just do
10 at a time, twenty at a time, thirty, you know,
just dumped memberships and we're going to try.
But in the meantime, you can still gift
individual memberships one at a time.
What a generous audience. Beautiful, Spencer
wrote in about my use of the term bad faith.
Spencer says, Hey, David, I've been watching your
show for well over a year now and have a request
that seems simple, but it may take
some time to elaborate on the answer.
Could you give a definition or explanation on the
phrase bad faith in terms of political questions
and comments? I personally haven't had an issue
agreeing with you whenever you use it. But it may
help others understand why you use that phrase to
dismiss certain talking points and ideas from both
the right and left. So here's the thing There's
two answers about what we mean by bad faith.
The first one is you sort of know bad faith
when you see it. And what I mean by that is
you might remember when I appeared on the Jesse
Lee Peterson show and he asked me, What is love?
And I knew that it was a bad faith question to
try to wrap me up into some kind of homophobic
thing. And so I didn't even take it
seriously. I said, You know, Oh, Jesse,
you know, love when you see it. It's sort of
ethereal, and I don't know what I said. I just
kind of laughed, laughed it off. But what we mean
by bad faith is that there's an intent to deceive
or that you are not being genuine in
your intention. So to give an example,
when Marsha Blackburn asks Judge Now just soon
to be justice kit Angie Brown Jackson What is a
woman? It's not that by definition, asking what a
woman is is a bad faith question. A five year old
would ask lots of questions that are just they
don't have the information yet. What is a woman?
OK, great. Or a three year old? I don't know
when kids ask, What's a woman? What's a man?
But the point of the question is
deceptive, it's not a mere curiosity,
it's a bad faith, an attempt to get Judge
Jackson to pigeonhole herself with one definition
which will then be turned and used against her for
political reasons. So with bad faith, you have to
understand context. Bad faith is sort of like a
dog whistle. The idea of a dog whistle is the same
way that if you blow a dog whistle, the dogs hear
it. But humans don't, or at least not as loud. OK.
It's the same type of thing with dog whistles,
where if I say if you didn't understand it.
Imagine that you're from a society that has
not had contact with the West, call it. OK.
And I say to you, Yeah, you know how I'm trying
to think of a good example. If I say to you, yeah,
there's we're going to look into the people
that control Hollywood like George Soros
and Steven Spielberg. It right? And
I list a bunch of Jewish people.
Unless you know what to listen for. You don't
realize that that's an anti-Semitic trope.
And much like with a dog whistle, you have to
be conditioned to hear it. You also have to
understand context to be able to identify bad
faith questions. I hope that I'm being clear.
I hope that I'm being clear in this,
but an important question for sure.
Dave wrote. And Dave says about my story on
Republican COVID deaths. David, you should
have mentioned their base is substantially older
than the Democrats. I would bet out of the 73000
Florida deaths you mentioned. You can add
another 20000 because they are older voters,
sixties to nineties. I bet 60 percent of
Republican at least great show. Yeah, we don't.
We just don't have the numbers. The question here
is about the Partizan death gap in COVID. We know
it skews towards Republicans. We just don't know
by how much, and we don't know if by enough to
make a difference in any midterm elections. But I
welcome any information we might have about that.
Keith wrote in with an idea. Here's an idea from
Keith David, Sir, as your show is an independent
operation, I know maintaining a workable revenue
stream is an ongoing effort. I have a one word
solution for you. Reruns reruns made the creators
of shows like Friends and Seinfeld Billionaires
or very nearly. So Why Not You? Reruns David
reruns. Well, I appreciate the support, Keith.
But there is a difference between the marble
rye and its replay value as a Seinfeld episode
and what was in the news on August 10th of 2012.
There's not that much replay value to news shows,
so I love the idea in practice, I don't
know if it works, but what does work is.
We will sometimes weave together themed episodes
where we say, let's take the issue of climate
and make an episode out of our best interviews
about climate change. We've done that. And people
generally like it. So that works. Just reruns,
reruns. I just don't know. They're good for a
few months, but I don't think anyone's going to
buy them. But I appreciate the thinking about how
to grow revenue. Last email today is from Doug,
who also signs his email. Brian, I don't know why
people do this. Anyway, it doesn't matter, Doug,
says David. Please refrain from using the phrase
guys or you guys. It's disrespecting the women in
your audience. Consider using folks or you folks.
Yet this is a regional thing in New England.
It's very common growing up. You just you just
used guys. It was inclusive of everybody. And I'd
never used folks. I never used use. I never used
y'all. I certainly don't intend to disrespect
any women. But if you agree with Doug or Brian,
maybe you agree with Brian and disagree
with Doug. I have no idea. This is from Doug
Brian. If you agree, disagree. Let me know your
thoughts. Is it offensive when I casually say,
Guys, I don't know if I can take this Republican
bias anymore? Am I being disrespectful to
women when I say that? Let me know we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today. Sign up at
Join Pacman Dot Com to instantly access the bonus
show. Also, remember that on Tuesday, April 19,
six p.m. Eastern will be doing the next David
Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall. It will be live
only on our second YouTube channel, Pacman
Live. That's YouTube.com slash Pacman life.